joining me now is arkansas senator tom
cotton senator
uh by smearing america uh team biden is
doing
china's job for them your reaction
yeah laura they are i mean it was
appalling to hear our ambassador to the
united nations play the role that is
normally played
by the chinese communist or the old
soviet ambassadors denouncing america as
a racist wicked place
we didn't even have to wait for china or
russia to do that the united nations
this week our own ambassador should do
that
it's disgraceful and she should resign
and then as you played the clips
of the chinese foreign minister in
alaska dressing down tony blinken
about america's perceived shortcomings
it sounds like you could have been at a
democratic party caucus meeting
laura or perhaps a seminar room on some
american college campus
repeating the exact same lies and
slanders against america and against our
founding principles
that the democrats have embraced
wholeheartedly you shouldn't be
surprised when chinese communists simply
parrot their words back to us
now the president of one of uh the un's
uh
bureaucracy senator in a columbia
university prof
he was visibly upset in an interview
with the bbc
when they dared to call out china's
human rights abuses abuses watch
i'm not sure why bbc started with
listing
only china's human rights abuses
what about america's human rights abuses
walking away from the paris climate
agreement
for the last four years unilateral trade
actions that have been deemed
illegal not to mention the continued
massive racism white supremacism
senator uh the self-loathing
and the virtue signaling i care more
about racism and the past sins of
america
i'm in anguish about it it strikes me as
utterly fraudulent and completely
poisonous to any hope of cooperating
with other countries against china
yeah and that clownish professor is
exactly what you hear the chinese
communists parroting back to us at a
time
laura when they have completely
obliterated the freedom and the autonomy
guaranteed to hang congress by their own
words when they have committing genocide
against religious minorities
in their own country sometimes in
turning them in concentration camps
by the millions by conducting gang mass
rapes on the orders of magnitudes
yet this professor is more worried about
america's supposed sins
then that those kind of actions by the
chinese communists it's just another
reason why so many of these united
nations organizations are a disgrace
oh it should just be completely defunded
now kerry
senator cotton isn't hiding his uh
weak approach to negotiating with china
watch this
yes we have big disagreements with china
on some key issues absolutely
but climate has to stand alone you know
you can't have those disagreements say
well because of that i'm not going to do
anything about climate because you're
just killing yourself
you're going to be hurting your own
people so hopefully everybody's going to
come to the table and be reasonable
wait a second is that the strategy i
said i'm like
i can't even believe i'm hearing this
your strategy is hopefully
and uh we'll we'll see how it goes we'll
figure it out
these chinas are chinese negotiators are
killers ask anyone
from bob lighthizer to mike pompeo to
everyone in the trump administration who
went toe-to-toe with him these are
killer negotiators
yeah laura this is like watching a bad
movie
with a b-list actor once again six years
ago
we sat we had john kerry sitting in
front of us and committee selling the
iran nuclear deal
this was the exact same line he used oh
the nuclear question will stand alone
we'll compartmentalize it from all other
issues like iran's support for terrorism
and their missile program their human
rights abuses and i said mr secretary
maybe you think it stands alone but the
ayatollahs don't
the same thing is true with these
chinese communists
they are not going to strike some
separate deal on climate change
without us sending every one of our jobs
to china and eliminating every
uh factory in america and sending to
china and surrendering
taiwan and turning a blind eye to their
grotesque human rights abuses and for
all that john kerry will come back
piecing our time with an agreement to
reduce carbon emissions in china by two
percent by the year 2082
that's the kind of deal that john kerry
is going to get if someone who's
responsible
doesn't step in yeah that's that's
that's what victory looks like in a
in a biden administration senator you
are such a leader on this issue thank
you so much
and